let's first ask about the fashion you've
gone full fringe always yeah it's just
my face I woke up one day and it was
there you know he was born with French
we're one of the only humans ever be
that have that uh you got a bolo on you
got the Hat why so country tonight
every night's country for me now so it's
like just keep it country country vibe
well we're here we are here at the
Grammys the first thing I got to ask you
guys about Kobe's at the top of
everybody's mind and I just wondered if
you had any thoughts you wanted to share
because it feels like we have to talk
about him tonight and we should I mean
it just doesn't feel real he was a
legend it's crazy to that it happens
today the Grammys here at Staples Center
we spent you know more than a decade
lighting this place up so but someone
that Kobe he's bigger than an icon you
know so it's as much as I he's gone he's
forever he's forever yeah I mean it's
incredibly tragic you know and like
we're all thinking about his family and
everyone and it's really sad day we're
thinking about it and then there's just
so much great music to honor tonight
what are you guys hoping to see happen
tonight up on that stage I want to see
Billy I'll apparently people crying
during her rehearsals my sister was
there she saw it she got a little tear
of course old town road I'm gonna be on
there on the stage there playing my
banjo solo and yeah it's gonna be it's a
great event although all the best people
here one day together having a party so
do you guys have dates tonight or a date
yeah Jonas Brothers also killing it
lately we try to get them a date but in
weekend they declined us thank you
[Music]